cnbc story
inflation speeds up in april as consumer
prices leap
4.2 percent fastest since 2008. now
when you read this story this is the
highest raise
rate of inflation over the past year
jumped from 4.2 to 2. from uh to 4.2
from 2.6 percent of prior month
highest since 2008 senior federal
reserve officials who are supposed to
protect the u.s
from high inflation insisting increases
temporary
they contend inflation will subside by
next year over the pandemic phase most
people go back to work and global
economy is
largely recovered now here's some
interesting statistic based on this okay
on what increased
energy prices overall jumped 25 from a
year earlier
49.6 increase for gasoline 37.3
for fuel oil then on top of that
this is the this is the random weird
statistic used car
and truck prices which are seen as a key
inflation indicator
surged 21 now what the hell is used car
prices going up 21
just in april alone it increased by that
little
you know lemon you're gonna buy for 200
bucks it's officially 2500 bucks
okay that the 10 000 truck you were
gonna buy
last year this you're gonna have to pay
twelve thousand two hundred dollars for
it
uh a used car so you know what's going
to happen with this
are the rates going to go up is you know
are they trying to kind of keep people
calm
they don't want to scare anybody lumber
prices alone have risen 124 percent in
2021 once again
lumber prices alone have risen 124
percent where are they saying it's from
though
what do they say they're just saying
it's just temporary it's not because you
know
based on what and copper often has seen
this proxy for economic activity has
jumped nearly 36 percent
by the way house is here you know what
kind of houses people are buying that
are they're moving here from new york or
other places
they're wanting to buy homes that have
already been fully built the tear downs
they're not there's there's not too many
teardown companies that's ridiculous
because of lumber being ridiculous
prices
right exactly building costs going also
in new york you get a you get a
shoe box for a million bucks down here
you're living the good life yeah
you are living a pretty good life at a
million bucks so but new yorkers stay in
new york
inflation no no right away tough
you know here's the problem with that
with new yorkers people from jersey
people from the northeast
you want to go to florida because you
feel safer
you want to go to florida because the
you know the the
the economy better yeah okay go to
florida
but don't bring your politics with you
keep your politics up there
don't come down that's hard to do and
try to vote the same way think the same
way
because thinking the same way isn't what
changed florida
your politics in new york city is far
different than what's going on in
florida
the politics in new york city is why
you're leaving new york city that's
exactly right right
so so you so either keep your ass up
there
or come to florida but you better stop
voting differently because otherwise
you're going to turn florida into new
york bernie why are all these guys from
new york why are they coming to florida
why aren't they going to alabama why
aren't they going to the lovely state of
mississippi
you know southern states south carolina
living in a country with a bunch
of sheep
you know i mean you weren't how are you
edison you were miserable hanging out
with your two cats more than any other
kid
i'm miserable with the cats man don't
bring the cats too little cats of yours
man yeah
so bernie i have a question for you
before we move on because you said you
got a lot of love down here you were
walking the streets of boca bae bernie
who are the people that are giving you
love hey barn good to see you and where
the people are like hey you
bernie get the hell out of it oh yeah
what's the difference
you get you get those for far and few
between but when you get them
yeah you know i'll tell you a quick
funny story i was crossing madison
avenue my
my little girl who's now 18. she was
about two years old this is
after 9 11 after giuliani and i
leave office i'm crossing madison avenue
up around nello's around 61st street
nice area i'm crossing the street and
there's a guy walking across he's like
your age
he's walking across the street facing me
and he goes
carrick right you carrick i see yes sir
and at the top of his lungs he goes
you're a dick
you're a dick he starts yelling
in the middle of the street and
everybody's like whoa
what happened what's who's this guy so
you get and it was bill de blasio you
probably is kid you get you get those
kind of people
that are complete lunatics but for the
most part
you know everybody's nice but down here
when i'm in palm beach or boca or
fort lauderdale i'm telling you i think
it's like a sixth borough of this city
because
everybody's like hey commissioner how
are you doing hey come here bernie
what's up
of new york and jersey i think they just
lifted up
like somewhere up there and brought it
down yeah and it's going to be more
because of what's going on with new york
this is not going to slow down
i can't tell you the numbers because
it's last night
you weren't at the house you were over
there i'm in the process of buying a
house right now okay we made a few
offers but this one's gone far
i get a call from my realtor yesterday
saying this guy is willing to
pay you xyz dollars i'll say it once the
house closes then i'll reveal the
information so people can know about it
there my realtor is telling me let this
guy buy the house from you i said i
haven't even bought the house yet yes
but legally this is your house because
you're in contract he wants to buy the
contract from you
and he wants to pay you this much i said
how am i so my wife says
babe it's a big number but please say no
she don't want to go through the process
because she's pregnant we got we got
what five weeks left
june 21st we got six weeks left for that
baby fourth baby to come up so
life is very busy right now but the
point is guys are coming in here they're
they're saying look what is what is the
asking price i'll give you two million
more i'll give you three just let me get
this place
because it's a it's the bidding war
today in florida it's
insane okay okay so that being said
what do you think in a year from now a
year and a half from now you think the
bubble's going to burst
not in states like florida texas
tennessee nevada it's not not those
states
really texas is going to take listen
texas is going to keep blowing up
florida's going to keep blowing up
tennessee's going to keep blowing up
nevada's going to keep blowing up
there are certain states they're not
going to want tennessee taxes
lowest taxes in all of america lowest
taxes in all of america
i'm actually going to tennessee i lived
there for two years it's one of the best
places to raise a family
one of the best places to raise a family
and it's not like country bumpkin
nationals no
they got all sports i mean nashville
especially you got you can go
live in a nice place brentwood national
brentwood nashville which got 10 50
million
20 million dollar homes you can go get a
quarter million dollar home and be right
outside the city
can you imagine a 20 million dollar home
in nashville it's a palace
i was going to say what's interesting
it's a so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye
you